[Music]
consider the given rectangular Channel
and 15 ft wide SLO gate after the
hydraulic jump the depth is measured at
10 ft and the velocity is at 5 ft per
second find the Freud number before the
jump so over here we have our
rectangular Channel we have a backlog of
water over here in a reservoir or
something we have the open SLO gate we
can see the water moving
through it here going up a hydraulic
jump and becoming a new depth over
here so this is section one this is
section two these corresponds to either
before the jump or after the jump so
I'll be the first to admit that I find
this problem annoying it's totally
solvable but it's going to make you
solve for a bunch of other unknowns on
both sides of the hydraulic jump before
you can solve for the actual Freud
number in second section one before the
jump which is what they're looking for
so let's get to
it step one we're going to want to solve
for the total flow in the
channel this part is
easy so
Q equals V2 A2 since we are given
the velocity after the
jump
so this is going to be 5 feet per second
times the area which is going to be the
15t width of the slle gate and the
channel and the 10t depth
measured solving for this we get Q =
750 fet cubed per
second step two let's find the Freud
number not in section one where it's
looking for but rather in section
two so the equation on page
343 is going to give us what we need so
F FR in this case is given as V over the
square < TK of G * y
subh so we've got our velocity which is
5T per second on that side of the
jump
32.2 ft/s squared
Time
10t Square
Root and this is going to give us a
Freud number of
0.28 this is good because it's less than
one and if we remember our information
about Freud number if it's less than one
it's in the subcritical region which we
can see over
here move moving on to step
three we're going to find the depth in
section one using the values found for
section two so this equation will come
from a group of equations on page
353 so find
y1
y1 over Y2 =
12 1
+ 8
* the Freud number in section 2
squared this quantity square rooted
minus1 that's an annoying thing to solve
but we can do it so y1 over 10t from Y 2
=
12 1 + 8 *
0.28
squared minus
one so again this is annoying to solve
in your calculator but if you do it
right you should come out to a y1 of
about
1.37
ft step four we are almost there solve
for solve for velocity in section
one so we know our Q so V1 in this case
is going to be Q over
A1 now that we have our y1 we can get A1
so that's going to
be
750 cubic feet per
second
over 15t because the width is constant
throughout the entire Channel times
1.37
ft and that's going to give us just
about
36.6 feet per
second five
finally we can
find the Freud number where it's asking
for before the hydraulic jump so it's
the same equation that we Ed to find
Freud number in the first
section we were just well in the second
section but Freud number the first time
now we have the terms we need to find it
in the first section before the
hydraulic
jump so f R1 equal
V1 over the square < TK of G sub y sub
1 sorry whatever I mumbled out there
um so
36.6 feet per second
over
32.2 feet perss squared time
1.37
ft square root
and if we get that we should solve for a
Freud number before the jump of
5.5 this logically makes sense as well
because the Freud number is greater than
one we can tell that this is in the
super critical region here granted all
of the answers are in the Super critical
region but this is the one it came out
to so keep in mind that this question
could have also asked you to solve for
Freud number in section two instead and
given you the values you needed from
section one so for that reason it's
probably worth reviewing the other
equations on page
353 just to see some of the other ways
that they could have expressed this and
things that you could have solved for
instead and that's
it